die geschichte dass aufrechten gang es
muss neu geschrieben werden das ist
tatsächlich so ein menschenaffe mit dem
spitznamen udo könnte vor 11,6 millionen
jahren gelebt haben und schmeißt jetzt
unseren bisherigen annahmen zufolge
alles über die entwicklung des
aufrechten ganges über den haufen die
spektakulären fossilienfunde von
danubius guggenmusik legen außerdem nahe
dass der erste aufrecht gehende menschen
aber nicht aus afrika kam sondern aus
deutschland vod klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
die fossilien entdeckte das tübinger
forschungsteam zwischen 2015 und 2018 in
11,6 millionen jahren alten
gesteinsformationen im allgäu in einem
bachlauf der tongrube hammerschmiede
konnten insgesamt 37 einzelfunde
versteinerter fossilien geborgen werden
und bei ihren ausgaben spürten die
fachleute nicht nur knochen sondern auch
schädelteile auf ein großes glück denn
die arm- und beinknochen sind noch fast
vollständig erhalten die analyse
enthüllt erstaunliches denn bei dem fund
handelt es sich um insgesamt vier
individuen einer bislang unbekannten
urzeitlichen primatenart das männliche
fossil bekamen dem spitznamen udo denn
sein unterkiefer wurde am 17 mai 2016
aufgespürt und das war der siebzigsten
geburtstag des sängers udo lindenberg
die analyse aus tübingen zeigt jetzt die
tiere mit der bezeichnung da nur yus
guggenmusik gehören zu den hominiden und
somit zu der stammes gruppe der menschen
und menschenaffen die affen waren wohl
rund einem meter groß und bis zu 31
kilogramm schwer
ein wenig erinnert er wohl an die
heutigen bonobos zumindest vom körperbau
her
die fachleute selbst feiern ihren schon
sehr denn es handelt sich um eine echte
premiere dazu
madelaine böhme die hauptverantwortliche
wissenschaftlerin
zum ersten mal konnten wir mehrere
funktionell wichtige gelenken darunter
ellbogen hüfte knie und sprunggelenk in
einem einzigen fossilen skelett dieses
alters untersuchen und die analyse zeigt
etwas was niemand erwartet hatte einige
der knochen ähneln
mehr den menschen als den menschenaffen
vor allem die kniegelenke die form der
schienbeine und die flache kniescheibe
deuten darauf hin dass diese hominiden
ihre beine komplett durch strecken
konnten auch weitere charakteristika
geben hinweise darauf dass diese
menschenaffen sich möglicherweise schon
aufrecht fortbewegt haben die fachleute
aus tübingen erkannten in ihrer analyse
beispielsweise dass da nur videos gucken
wo sie eine flexible lendenwirbelsäule
besessen haben muss ein indiz dafür dass
er seinen rücken krümmen und den massen
schwerpunkt seines körpers senkrecht
über beine und füße verlagern konnte ein
wirklich überraschendes und sogleich
sensationelles ergebnis denn das
tübinger forschungsteam ist sich jetzt
ziemlich sicher dass sich diese menschen
affen schon vor knapp 12 millionen
jahren aufrecht auf zwei beinen bewegt
haben dazu schreibt das forschungsteam
in seiner studie
das spricht für einen zumindest
zeitweilig aufrechten gang
diese erkenntnis widerspricht allen
bisherigen annahmen und stellt die
entwicklung des aufrechten ganges
komplett auf den kopf denn die ältesten
funde die auf einen aufrechten gang
hindeuten stammen aus kreta und aus
kenia und sind lediglich 5,7 millionen
jahre alt die aktuelle untersuchung
datiert den aufrechten gang also sechs
millionen jahre früher als bisher
angenommen wurde
dabei ist das ganze rätsel um die
entwicklung des aufrechten gangs schon
uralt seit der evolutionstheorie von
charles darwin versuchen
forschungsdienst weltweit endlich
antworten auf diese fragen zu finden
entstand das zwei beinen gelaufen durch
das hangeln und klettern in bäumen oder
aber entwickelte es sich aus dem
vierbeinigen knöchel gang sowie sich
noch heute gorillas und schimpansen also
unsere engsten verwandten fortbewegen
die datenlage dazu ist widersprüchlich
und es fehlt an eindeutigen
fossilienfunden die aktuellen funde aus
dem allgäu legen eine einzigartige
kombination da die hände und arme von
danubius sprechen für das hangeln an
ästen seine beinen wirbelknochen dagegen
legen nahe dass er sich zwei beine und
aufrecht fortbewegt haben muss dazu
ziehen die tübinger forschende den
rückschluss dass diese hominiden beide
arten nutzen um vorwärts zu kommen und
das ist wirklich einmalig unter den
primaten dazu heißt es in der studie die
einzigartigkeit dieser fortbewegung
besteht darin dass sie nicht
entweder die vorder- oder hinter ex
premier täten bevorzugt sondern beide in
etwa gleichem maße nutzt heißt also im
klartext dieser uhr an der menschen
gingen mit gestreckten beinen und
ausgerichtet über dem boden war aber
auch in der lage sich elegant durch die
baumkronen zu hangeln und zu schwingen
diese kombination der beiden
fortbewegungsweise könnte nach ansicht
der forscher
der vorläufer weiterer bewegungsformen
gewesen sein heißt also nicht nur das
schwingen der orang utans sondern auch
der knöchel gang der gorillas könnte
sich ebenso wie der aufrechte gang der
früh menschen daraus entwickelt haben
diese erkenntnis wird in der fachwelt
als sensation gefeiert dazu die
wissenschaftlerin madeleine böhme die
funde aus süddeutschland sind ein
meilenstein der paläoanthropologie denn
sie stellen unsere bisherige sichtweise
auf die evolution der großen
menschenaffen und des menschen
grundlegend in frage
doch nicht nur die entwicklung des
aufrechten ganges könnte damit
möglicherweise erstmalig erforscht
worden sein
die aktuellen funde aus dem allgäu sind
auch noch anderweitig eine große
überraschung denn bislang gegen
fachleute davon aus dass sich der
aufrechte gang und die gemeinsamen
vorfahren der menschenaffen und menschen
aus afrika stammen
doch möglicherweise ist das nicht der
fall und die wiege liegt in europa laut
der wissenschaftlerin madeleine böhme
ist es quasi ausgeschlossen dass es noch
ältere aufrecht gehende menschenaffen in
afrika gegeben haben könnte dass sich
der prozess des aufrechten gangs in
europa vollzog erschüttert die
grundfesten der paläoanthropologie
weitere analysen könnten diese theorie
bekräftigen und genau darauf hoffen die
forscher
denn nicht nur die anderen bereits
aufgespürten fossilien sind gut erhalten
schon bald könnten weitere ausgrabungen
im allgäu erfolgreich verlaufen und neue
funde hervorbringen dazu madeleine böhme
das muss man sich vorstellen wie ein
puzzle in das immer mehr teile eingefügt
werden was uns mumien erzählen anklicken
anschauen und über raum tv abonnieren
sehr sehr cooler kanal bis dann bleibt
dran